- It tastes like brains.
(thunder crashing)
- Today we're trying zombie frappuccinos.
- I personally love the idea
of all these crazy frappuccinos.
- Hopefully it's not too scary.
- I actually prefer Starbucks
over local coffee places.
- I almost broke down
and got the unicorn one.
- What made you like, compelled to try it?
- The color.
- Zombie time.
- Ooh!
- What?
- It's like a work of art.
- Brains.
- It does look like Frankenstein.
- It's like half a unicorn and
half a disgusting dead thing.
- Oh my god, it looks like a sculpture.
- It's not scary, it's more cute.
- I see purple, I'm like,
"Ooh, this is gonna be grape flavored,"
but it's just whipped cream.
- I think that's blueberry.
That looks like blueberry to me.
- I taste banana in this.
Am I tripping?
- I taste apple.
- It doesn't make me think
zombie, though, when I see this.
- It makes me think of like, fairies.
- It's actually not that sweet to me.
- I like the combination
of all the flavors.
- Mm-hmm, it's very random though
'cause the top tastes totally
different from the inside.
- I get a little bit of
green apple with some caramel
and then an odd like, hint of chocolate.
- This is good for like,
like a birthday party
for someone who really likes Starbucks.
- It's like kiwis.
- There were like 12 flavors in that sip.
- This tastes like a caramel apple.
If that's what it's supposed
to be, it's pretty accurate.
- I mean, I taste banana still.
I don't taste apples at all.
- I would much rather just have coffee
and have some fro yo separately.
- Keep incorporating food.
Maybe throw some kale in there next time.
- No, that's too much.
- It's like you're drinking
three different Starbucks drinks in one.
- I'd be so terrified of the amount
of the calories that are in this.
- Do we have our daily value of sugar
just drinking it from here to here?
- Yeah, this is like a
week's worth of sugar.
- Yeah.
- I just don't know if I could like,
walk into a place and be like, order this
and then walk out like a normal person.
- I wanna see like a vampire one,
which is just completely red,
maybe with like, black
whipped cream on top.
That would be so cool.
- A Santa one, you know.
- What would it taste like?
A guy that touches kids?
- I would like to see a griffin.
It's not associated with a
holiday, but it's very cool.
(upbeat music)